all right let's talk to some folks from
the audience
to hear what is on folks minds another
very busy week of news with more
upcoming and many different things going
on including great news on
uh vaccinations covid cases declining
but still
many challenges ahead and uh so many
different things going on we will do it
via discord as we have been doing for
several months and it is working
it's working well i would say
davidpakman.com
discord let's go first to anna
from vietnam anna from vietnam you're on
the air
oh hello yes how are you i'm so
i'm sorry i'm getting so nervous oh
please don't be nervous how are you
i'm nervous because we've never had a
caller from vietnam before
yeah i'm nervous because this is the
first time i've ever made a call to
anyone kind of famous before oh i was
i thought you were going to say this is
the first time you've ever spoken to
anyone via digital means i was going to
be surprised
yeah that that that'd be odd so what's
going on
what can i do for you anna but yeah i
have
like heard and i've seen like in some
social medias that there there's been
an uprising racism against asian people
in the us yes so i want to know if you
acknowledge that and i want to know what
are your thoughts about it
i guess yeah i i believe that i mean
listen
i have no personal i follow the science
and the data
and a number of uh well-respected
um organizations that track hate
incidents have seen
that since the start of the pandemic in
the united states there have been
significantly larger numbers of um
hate incidents against asian folks uh
believed anna to be because donald trump
kept talking about china china china the
china virus the kung flu
etc etc so i think that
um i mean my view is that it's
disgusting and it's despicable
and that we should be able to
simultaneously say
china's not being transparent we have a
diplomatic problem with china
without fomenting random
attacks on asian people in the street
you know these are two different things
it's disgusting yeah i understand and
uh yeah i just want to make sure that we
are not like
being super conflicting on this i know
that it's not like the best source
to get your information from like from
just social media
in general because i have heard a lot of
people like having
um like actual thoughts about it
via like science stuff and paperwork and
things like that
but to be able to like have it so
obvious that even
the sources that are not supposed to
give you like specific and very accurate
information about it like
talking about it is quite huge you know
and um
to me the america has always been a
place where you can
be free and uh kind of like achieve your
american dream so
to see that happen to my people is very
upsetting and very unsettling
in a way i completely agree with you and
and understand how how horrible that
must be
anna you speak beautiful english how
would tell us about how
did you learn english in school in
vietnam
oh thank you
oh i'm sorry um so this
[Music]
because yeah i formulated my thoughts
before
calling oh okay but i'm getting like
nervous
i have everything no you're doing great
you're doing great anna listen i wish my
american callers took a moment to
formulate their thoughts before they
called
they could really take a lesson from you
my pleasure anna thank you anna from
vietnam
uh as close to a perfect phone call
as i can imagine let's go next to jared
from new york
jared you're on the air
david um i know you've interviewed ken
jennings
in the past which was real cool yes for
people who don't know
the many many time winner of jeopardy
yes i was wondering if um you've seen
any of the new episodes where he's taken
over as host
um and if you have any thoughts on kind
of how he's done or
what they're going to be doing what
they're going to be bringing on guest
hosts so i just wonder if you had any
thoughts on that no
i haven't seen an episode of jeopardy in
probably a decade
and i haven't watched a live tv show as
it's airing
other than sports or news for almost as
long so i have no i didn't even know he
was hosting jeopardy to be quite honest
yeah he he took over on an interim basis
and it's interesting it's tough because
it's
it's hard to kind of get used to his
style after seeing out for so long but
yeah yeah that's all i just wanted to
get your thoughts are you like a i know
that jeopardy fans are very
adamant like they they they watch every
episode is
has this been a huge thing in the
jeopardy community
oh yeah it's been a very big thing um
it's just there's a lot of discussions
of is it is people find it a little odd
but is it because they're not used to it
is it because he's just new and he'd
have to get more comfortable or
is it because he's just not you know a
great host interesting so everybody
and then the guests coming up are
interesting it's people like anderson
cooper
will be guest hosting and katie couric
but then you have like
aaron rodgers who's an nfl quarterback
so
they're they're taking an interesting
approach i would like to guest host
maybe we can get a campaign going i
would be interested in doing that
that would be really cool for sure all
right well let's uh let's make it happen
it sounds like you're kind of an insider
in this community i think you have the
power
absolutely absolutely all right thank
you dave okay thanks jared from new york
and i'm not kidding
i expect to hear from you about guest
hosting